that's one second that's Mariah Carey
and her eight-year-old twins Monroe and
Moroccan having a little fun while
demonstrating proper hand washing
technique amid coronavirus concern the
trio
soaked up and scrubbed away to the
singer's hit song fantasy while making
sure to follow the CDC's a recommended
strategy washing for 20 to 30 seconds
the singers career has been affected by
recent health concern she was forced to
cancel her March 10th concert in
Honolulu a week before she was set to
perform Mariah's concert was rescheduled
for November 28th of course she's not
alone most Hollywood events have been
canceled or postponed due to the
pandemic and in the meantime celebs are
keeping us entertained by joining the
viral hand-washing trend
[Music]
that's Gloria Gaynor sending a very
clear message that she won't let covet
19 get her down other Hollywood stars
like Gwyneth Paltrow Pete Hudson and
Bella Hadid have posted about wearing
preventative masks while traveling and
then there's Naomi Campbell who opted
for an entire hazmat suit
[Music]